a der spiegel te den spiegel externas
en master quest learning steiner
speaks los leones de yucatán isstey
buenos días aquí steve
por supuesto voy a hablar sobre el
aprendizaje de idiomas y sobre dos
factores dos ingredientes que son muy
muy importantes en el aprendizaje de
idiomas y esos son la paciencia y el
realismo
por ejemplo estoy estudiando ucrania
bueno
sobre todo estoy escuchando un
audiolibro y leyendo el mismo libro
sobre la historia de ucrania
y no es cada día que tengo el
sentimiento de que comprendo mejor pero
hoy tenía esta sensación
y es por decir que no es cada día que
sentimos que tenemos esta satisfacción
que estamos progresando en el idioma
pero si continuamos por ejemplo ahora yo
leo cosas en ucrania y escucho y
comprendo mucho más que hace unos unos
meses
pero era durante este periodo de un mes
que estoy concentrándome en el cráneo
era bueno el días en que me parecía que
tantas palabras que no conozco es muy
difícil probable pero hay que continuar
hay que tener paciencia y también hay
que ser realista por ejemplo
hablando con mi tutor en ucrania
y yo consigo con ese siempre algo los
mismos errores y todo pero hay que
pensar a las cosas que es que somos
capaces de hacer en el idioma no a los
problemas no entonces ahora estoy
hablando en español aunque hace haga
hace hagan aunque pero no hace mucho
tiempo que no hablo español
voy a hacer los errores pero lo
importante es que puedo comunicarme
comunicar con vosotros este es lo más
importante y siempre tenemos que tener
paciencia con todo lo las cosas que no
todavía no comprendamos comprendemos yo
no sé puede ser no importa porque
tenemos que tener paciencia con las
cosas que no entendemos con las cosas
que nos estamos capaces de exprimir y
todo eso no es porque tú vas a estudiar
a algunas reglas de gramática o pasar
una estudiar en un curso de inglés o de
lo que sea
podría podrías entonces hablar
perfectamente en el idioma no es una
progress es un proceso
como se dice un proceso es no es un
proceso yo no sé es un trabajo que
continua para que para creer nuevos
hábitos en el cerebro el cerebro y éste
necesita tiempo siempre necesita tiempo
para aprender un idioma muy distinto de
su propio idioma
por ejemplo el chino pero también el
inglés si ustedes vosotros sois
hablantes de español y también por
idiomas muy parecidos por ejemplo yo
hablo de ruso pero para acostumbrarme al
al ucranio éste necesita tiempo para que
automáticamente voy utilizar la palabra
en ucraniano el palabra la palabra ruso
cuando el deporte es cuando veo empecé a
fallar aportó 10 era muy difícil muchas
difícil porque es ee uu
tengo que pensar cada vez en cada
palabra se hizo y una vez una palabra en
portugués o español eso no imposible
entrar posible pues sigo en tal tenía
tenía que crear nuevos hábitos en mi
cerebro e hizo es el caso
o que sea
la lengua que estamos aprendiendo para
volver al español y para terminar
entonces tenemos que ser realistas y
tener paciencia porque es el descubierto
y el último suceso éxito en el
aprendizaje de idiomas pues es una larga
camino es una larga camino tenemos que
gozar del idioma y tenemos que tener
paciencia porque de esa manera vamos a
continuar hasta la última meta bueno
este es todo gracias y hasta hasta la
próxima vez
[Música]